so long my charge was to give some
survey about classical repetition and
move to describe a recent results about
that repetition of them tango if we had
used a veg fire and video so we've seen
this many times and afford not to
describe it again so this is my
animation for a two player one round
game it's given by a bipartite graph a
set you envy and question pair is just
an edge between a vertex you and vertex
V and this edge has a constraint on it
you noted by UV in the semantics of the
game or as usual so there's two players
Allison Bob and a verifier the very far
selects an edu v eight random sends you
to Alice and Vito Bob and then Alice
needs to respond with some answer alpha
Bob responds with the better and based
on the constraint päivi the verifier
decides if they win the game so if alpha
beta the peril for beta is in the
constraint they win so classically Alex
Bauer required not to communicate with
each other meaning they can communicate
all they want before the game begins but
after Alice received you and Bob
received V they're not allowed to talk
to each other and this means that alex's
strategy is really just a function of
her question you she can be randomized
but it turns out that that won't help
her so she might as well be
terminus they can just be a function
from the questions you to the alphabet
the answer set Sigma and similarly for
Bob it's just a function from the
questions me to the answer set Sigma the
value of the games just the maximum over
all possible strategies f4 above and G
for Alice here of the fraction of
question pairs UV or edges UV for which
their answer is satisfy the constraint
so that's the classical value so example
we've already seen but I want to go
through it now is the three sub game so
let's start with a three-set instance so
it's a bunch of boolean variables to x1
to xn and the collection of clauses it
clauses in or of three literals x1 or
not x 2 or x 7 for example so this is a
3 sub formula and from this we can
construct the game by just looking at
the clauses as possible questions for
Bob and the variable is possible
questions for Alice we can call it the
clause versus variable game the game
goes as follows the verifier chooses a
random Clause sends it to buff and the
random variable among the three
variables of the clause and sends that
to Alex ok so for example here above but
this clause X naught X I or X I prime or
I double Prime and one of these three
variables is excised so Alice get sex I
and then what are they supposed to
answer Bob is supposed to give some
assignment to this clause it satisfies
it so 0 1 0 is a good answer and Alice
gives an assignment to X I and they
won't if the assignment is consistent if
the value that Bob get gave to X is
consistent with the value that Alice k
and that's that's a description of the
game now it's very easy to see that if
the twitch that had a satisfying
assignment then the players have a
perfect strategy right Alice can just
use this assignment as
strategy for a XII she will answer
according to this assignment and Bob can
also use this assignment for his
strategy for every class he will give
you know the value of this assignment on
the class and they would win probability
1 moreover if the preset was not
satisfiable they cannot win with
probability 1 because whether what
strategy Alex uses if you look at it as
if it's an assignment you know it's
there is no satisfying assignment so
there will be some closet is violated
and Bob is in trouble on this cloud
because Bob don't know what to answer
and no matter what Bob answers on this
clause either it's he gives an
unsatisfiable value which will cause him
to lose immediately or he gives some
satisfiable value on this clause it must
be inconsistent with at least one of the
variables so the three that is
satisfiable if and only if the value is
one of this game
wrote that the strategy for alice is
really just an assignment a strategy for
Bob Bob Santa Claus a number from one to
seven because there's always seven
possible satisfying assignment which
closed this leads me to this equivalence
between games and constraint
satisfaction problems which we conceive
speed we call by the name of label cover
the problem of giving this game this
constraint graph the computational
problem finding the value of this game
is called label column so I think what I
just showed you is that level cover is
np-complete because there's a reduction
from 3sat you can also view Lego cover
itself as a constraint satisfaction
problem because you know each of the
questions is like a variable and each of
the edges is like a constraint so it's a
two local constraint satisfaction
problem and on the other hand what we
size that every constraint satisfaction
problem not only three set and a TC SD
gives rise to this clause versus
variable V so goes both ways and it's a
very syntactic and simple transformation
another name for these games is smooth
deeper interactive proofs MIP in an
early name for this fees or constraint
satisfaction problems are PCP
probabilistically checkable proofs and
what i just talked about is the
equivalence between my AP and PCP in
this content and we know in we've
discussed this week that when you try to
add quantum nests into these two models
somehow the quantum list gets added in
different ways and the equivalents
doesn't work anymore so 12 version of
CSP is very different from the quantum
version of the game but I'm not going to
talk about quantum just yet let me still
stick around with the classical stuff so
going back to the complexity of label
cover so what I just showed is that Leo
cover is np-hard and so it's NP hard to
decide if a given game has value 1 or
not it's also NP hard to decide if the
value is 1 or something bounded away
from one that's considered a hardness of
approximation with that and that's
basically the PCP theorem and in fact
you can even get a gap as large as you
want so it's hard to decide if the value
is 1 or you know no more than any small
epsilon that you want in this we can
call the strong PCP theorem so for the
benefit of the non computer science
people we just say a few words about the
Pacific prevent the beginning of the
Randy's there's many ways to describe it
the one that we usually like and think
its host it is most interesting is in
terms of proofs checking that you know
someone writes you a proof you don't
need to read the entire proof it's
enough to read a randomly selected
number constant number
it's in check that the poop is cool but
for me it's more convenient to think of
it as a gut-level cover anything harness
so just the PCP here is just equivalent
to saying that it's NP hard to decide
leave a late if value of a game is won
or bounded away from how do you prove
this theorem by reduction from I don't
know three sides you basically do a gap
amplification you start from the label
cover instance that you got from 3sat
where you know it's and if you hard to
decide if the value is one or not and
you transform it to a new level coverage
equine such that if the old clever cover
had perfect value so there was perfect
strategy for that game then there is a
perfect strategy for this game level
cover has value one and if the value was
less than one then after the
transformation the value becomes they
bounded away from one so somehow the gap
between the Essendon no cases which here
was there was no gap really was just
like one over polynomial a small gap it
became amplified to a constant factor as
I said there's a strong PCP theorem
where the gap is not only between 1 and
1 minus epsilon it's between one and a
small epsilon and how do you get that
well this transformation there's also
some reduction but I wrote it explicitly
because it's such a simple and appealing
transformations just take the game G
prime and play it in parallel k times
work a sufficiently large to to get this
thing yeah so basically take the
parallel repetition is this level cover
and voila you get that if the value is 1
it stays 1 it's always true classic and
if the value was bounded away from one
then the value goes down to a chill
that's a strong PCP
how do you prove this part moving from
some tiny gap to a constant yeah so
there's one way to prove it is through
there in the original ways to algebraic
encoding you take the variables of this
label cover and you encode it in some
logical extension some more things and
another way is a convenient way that's
more related to parallel repetition
essentially it's a dual randomized
parallel repetition it's very appealing
to kind of amplifier gap between the s
and no instances by some kind of
repetition and even if the gap is very
small you can still try to do it take
the parallel repetition and the grab
through a little bit and take the
parallel position again the gap who is
that a question realize that the
launching production but they have never
seen it as a randomized for repetition
okay yeah so why it's doing okay so
thanks for the question right so yeah so
I guess it's one of the points I want to
make it it is a real un demise parallel
repetition let me first just say why I
said and then try to explain why so way
if I just applied parallel reputation
repeatedly I would be in bad shape
because every time you apply power
repetition what you're doing essentially
is instead of looking at all the
questions you're looking at something
like all k tuples of questions and so if
you do it again and again the size of
your instance blows up very large so we
can't afford to do it sufficiently many
times to increase the gap from one over
polynomial to a constant but if you
manage to get addie randomized parallel
repetition and by that what we mean is
instead of looking at all possible cake
toppers you look at a small subset of
kate up and say linear in so n is the
number of questions in your game k is
you know the parameter of federal
petition so you want linear in n not
fully nominally mean number of cake
apple instead
the gap amplification then that would
qualify as d randomized parity and in
this proof this is what we do we look at
Kate uppers of question parents they'll
say more managed to amplify the gap a
little bit and then we do some
correction step because the alphabet
grows too much so reduce alpha me and do
again d randomized parallel kitchen
increase the gap some more do a
correction step and so on and so on
until you get a constant so that's like
a two-line description of the proof
there isn't maybe you're not used to
think of it as de rennes demise parallel
repetition is because usually we
describe it as if you know you look at
the constraint graph and you look at a
bunch of vertices in this graph but
don't want to get too much into the
detail so let's do this I may get the
end of the talk if you want to ask me
again I can explain in more detail
whites they are under my spell
repetition okay I think I start on the
stairs I think the reason I did not
I addition to position of a point right
but now I realize that actually that
neighbor was not 3d a neighborhood
because you forced expand their breath
upon your structures so that was
actually it the neighborhood was the
architect of this pseudo random way of
selecting many many points right but
even if it wasn't first a neighborhood
is sunk a couple of questions of course
it's very specific in that way it's D
randomized so it's not all possible cake
toppers it's only these neighborhoods
but yeah okay so when I guess the point
of this discussion is that you know
feral repetition orderin demise parallel
petition is useful for this
amplification ferg a complication so let
let me talk a little bit more about
replication I took the simplest to
analyze repetition is just sequential
repetition that's like the first thing i
would do if i needed to amplify again i
have some game and i know there is some
gap between the yes and in all cases
i'll just run the game twice and i'm
claiming the gap will grow and by this
what i mean is that you know if it was a
yes instance i would accept always so
this doesn't change if i run it twice
but if this was a no instance then you
know the airport will give the game is
the probability of accepting even though
i should have rejected so if i run the
game twice you know I'm doubling the
probability of finding of rejecting okay
so the probability that i accept twice
is now exponential into if i do it tee
times it becomes exponential in t okay
so if i want to gain Tyrion's first if
not catching error is exponentially in t
and you know if you don't want to think
of Tiryns with the same to prove or you
can also think of you know having to t
provers and you play the game with these
two separately and independently with
these two and so on so you have to t
provers and the probability
not catching a problem is again
experiential et now how does this
translate back to a CSP so it's very
natural to think of a game and rounds or
many provers but in terms of the CSP
what's going on is that for example if
you think of this to tip over situation
it's like you're reading simultaneously
to t bits from the proof okay instead of
just reading two bits or two answers
you're looking to t answers so if you
translate this back to OCS day at around
the game it's not a to local CSP age
rather it's a tutti local okay so just
this make sense oh so it's not t local
but on the other hand it has all these
other knives property right the number
of bits you read from the truth is
linearity and the error that you get is
exponential in T and that's you can
think about if it's a it's optimal up to
now off factor so and in fact the one
thing that's not optimal here is the
fact that i'm wasting a lot of
randomness to rerun the game again and
again and i'm using t times log n bits
of randomness but this can easily be
fixed you can actually use t plus log n
bits of randomness and this would give
you like the optimal parameters for this
kind of game and what you would get is
like the sequential inspiration for the
sliding scale conjecture it's it's a CSP
that has all the correct properties like
the sliding scale conjecture that Donna
talked about you know the only problem
with it is that the constraints are two
to yoga and not to say of one local why
do we insist on this to local or of one
local so two local firm in particular is
most desirable because it's very useful
for proving hardness of a fox
if you prove NP hardness some of this
thing with two local cities then you can
use it to prove stuff for example about
breath problems because you know graphs
are also these two local things right
edges are between two vertices so you
can kind of use breath problems to
simulate to local constraints and this
will prove that solving the graph
problem is as hard as solving the thing
that you assume is hard so anyway
summarize this part and just saying that
the sequential repetition is like moving
from a constant locality CSP to 1t local
system that's not hard to do getting it
back to a constant localities it feels
like instead of sequential repetition
doing parallel application so this is
alray approach I mean there could be
other ways and in fact there are
algebraic ways to reduce the number of
the locality of cs piece that are very
successful but you know in the context
of this session i'm talking about
clarification so another way that we can
try to reduce the error of a game or to
amplify the gap is by parallel my
position so now we have a picture for
parallel repetition so here we have two
games one is G in one is G prime and
we're playing it in parallel so what
does that mean it means that the
verifier they're still just two players
Alison Bob a very fire now chooses one
edge at random UV from this game and
independently and editor and mu prime V
prime from this game ok and then the
verifier sends the to you endpoints u
and u prime are sent to Alex and V in V
prime are sent to Bob and Alice needs to
give an answer both to the question you
in G and to the question you find in G
Prime and Bob gives us answers to Vienna
define that I'm discipline and of course
they won't if I find better satisfy the
first constraint mg and alpha prime and
that
and satisfy the second constraint in G
so that's playing these two games in
parallel again I'm in classic situation
there's no communication between Alice
and Bob and so their strategies really
functions it nap every pair of questions
to add it at their skits she gives the
pairs of caravans and every pair of
questions that Bob gets he gives a pair
of appearances now if you want to
understand what the game is what the
constraint graph is you can't just do
these two games separately you need to
combine them and understand what the
game is that corresponds to this this
protocol and when you do that you
realize that the game is a very nice
thing the questions on Alice's side are
just the product of the questions you x
you find the questions on website is
just V times V Prime and you have an
edge between you your prime if there's
an edge on e along each coordinate so
it's a kind of a tensor Pretender
product between these two games it will
see later exactly that it's a tensor
product of the proper operator so you
know we define parent petition we've
also defined the product operation
between two games and so we've defined
the product between two games and you
can generalize it to pay product of K
copies of G and then you know Alex's
questions with the old case happens you
one of two UK but this question will be
Kate up as vianney position and so on so
now you know what are natural questions
to ask you one question is so you have
to gain is h or I guess g1 and g2 and
you know something about their values
right so the value of g one it's
something only go on the value of g2 is
omega2 can you say something about the
value of g1 s g2 I think this is a very
natural question
it's a hard question which is maybe why
people ask the following slightly easier
question which is if you know something
about the value of G and you take the
patty repetition with k going to
infinity what can you say about the
value of GT ok so one thing you can say
that the value of G to the K is always
at least alpha to the king because the
players can always play a product
strategy Alice can always you know she
sees a bunch of questions you want up to
UK she can answer each one of them
according to the strategy for just G in
soapy involved in which case still value
their value will be just as fertility
the trouble is that that's not the best
thing they can do sometimes they can do
much better that's a source of you know
that's why maybe these questions are
interesting
so say some history about these things
so initially it was conjectured this
federal petition behaves exactly like
sequential repetition but quickly this
turned out to be false it was discovered
that there are games where the value of
playing the game twice is exactly the
same as the value of playing the game
once so in that sense maybe an answer to
my first question of what can you say
about the value of G times H if you know
the value of genuine not evaluate maybe
you can't say much but nevertheless it
was proven that if you take k to go to
infinity the value goes down to zero and
fire and pinion were maybe the first
approved an explicit bound and they
showed that the value goes down pouring
normally with k if the initial value
goes down there only from one and then
there's a very famous theorem by none
last called the parallel repetition
theorem where it pooped for every game
that if the value is down there away
from one then the value of the repeated
game goes down exponentially with the
number of repetitions
then this was a consequently improved
and simplified and for projection games
we know that the value is 1 minus
epsilon squared over some constant
raised to the cake yeah they had to add
some other some other questions confuse
compare questions is true but the
original of us is without just the
normal just the vanilla repetition just
take the game repeated and then there in
the past few years there has been a lot
of interest in getting this two down to
a one because there was a potential a
very nice application of this you can
take our max cut instance take the
parallel repetition of it and get a
unique games instance and if the value
elected instance is X or a game so it's
a very special game maybe you know for
these games by repetition is even be
even better and you can get 1 minus
epsilon and if that were the case you
would get a reduction from the hardness
of Max cut to the hardness of unique end
where we know the converse we know that
if unique angel heart than max cut is
hard so that would have been a really
nice thing and people really try to
improve that but it turned out that it
parallel petition won't give us this
result and that these two must be there
and this is a beautiful example of when
Rollins showing you know am upset game
of soccer game where the value is going
like this one in seconds
so finally just to say so the main
application of this theorem is for
hardest approximation basically what i
showed you in the beginning now to start
from our PC Peter and get to a strong
tcp here amplifying the gap of Labor
cover to be between you know one and any
tiny dancer so now it's know the answers
well I guess I guess no but since then
there is another work of long laws and
Dinah Moskowitz that give strong PCP
theorem without parallel petition and
you know in some respect much better
parameters because the size is almost
linear and not like explained to
anything so that's much better it's
worth in some other relationship between
the or alphabet but okay are you right
actually and the [ __ ] Killian but these
are parallel repetitions it just not
runs as a result but it's true that it's
fair repetition yeah there's also other
results that show a very very large gap
but not with two local constraints with
kinds of one local what is the
projection game all right so I'm going
to get there to say in one sentence it's
a game where the constraints have this
form where the answer of Bob determines
the answer of Alex but yeah it's been a
slide on it may be wrong side of things
so when okay now moving to the entangled
value so you know that is the value of a
game against still the same thing
exactly it's given by level cover
the only thing is that the strategy is
allowed for Alice and Bob are slightly
different now they're sharing
entanglements so that the strategy for
alex is no longer function from her
questions two answers but rather for
every question Alice needs to decide
upset about the set of measurements and
then she measures and based on the
outcome of the measurement she gives an
answer in similarly 2 purl loops so
right so the semantics are will be
different basically the strategies is
something like this for every question
you you have a collection of matrixes
that describe this measurement so what
do we know about the pile repetition for
the entangled value of the game so
another gains classic case that we've
been discussing here or the know
nonstick living games where the
strategies for Alice and Bob are
expected to be done signaling for this
we know polym stain proved our parallel
petitions goes down exponentially and
then it was proven that parallel
petition for X or games is also with an
exponential decay this was then extended
to unique games and for general games or
not just unique a campaign Vedic prove
the prepetition theorem that's analogous
to the [ __ ] killian a proven actually
they also I think they're proof followed
the fake alien reasoning make sure the
polynomial is decaying them so the value
goes down like a polynomial in k1 over
pulling on it okay and then recently
there have been a free works I guess
presented this afternoon
exponentially decaying competition for
various restrictions and what I'm going
to talk about is a very high repetition
for classes games called projection
games of projection constraint games
there are theories this if the entangled
value of the single game is 1 minus
epsilon then the value of the repeated
game goes down like 1 minus epsilon to
the for a race to the king so go down
exponentially oh he does prove abound I
just don't others know it's exponential
is its financial it proves the father
and exponentially decaying part of it
too but for non signaling strategies so
it doesn't imply anything from the
entangled value
it might be the denouncing value is 10
see that so if it is not one bit
stronger right yeah
okay so what are games with their
projection constraints again it's
projection if for every question pair
there's a very specific structure on the
constraint where the answer from Bob
determines only one unique valid answer
four minutes okay so it's only if these
are two questions u and V and here you
think of the clause versus variable game
so Alice has two possible answer answers
in Bob and some I don't know why five
here possible answers then you know for
every answer for Bob there's exactly one
possible answer for Alice that would
make the players win the game actually
can be inputs given the inputs the
questions yeah so you know for for b1
dancers they want for B to the answer is
a two for B 3 the answer is anyone so
you see that they knickknacks is one way
it's just that Bob's answer determines
Alice's answer but not Alice's answer
determining Bob's answer if the
uniqueness was both ways then we would
call these unique it's going one way
it's called projection okay and I guess
most of the games if we know our
projection games so extra games are
projecting games unique as our
projection games here are a number of
other games are all projection game but
some gains are not predicting right so
there is this hidden matching game you
can invent many games without not
protection but bear in mind that there
is a very simple transformation that
takes any game and converts it into a
projection however and this information
is something like the closed versus
variable transformation you know but I'm
not going to describe it exactly and the
value stays roughly the same if it was
one it stays one and if it's bounded
away from one
it stays boundary for one but this is
only true for the classical value for
entangle value solution can do a lot of
harm and really ruin the inside so it
might be that the entangled value is
high but then after the transformation
it drops okay so in that sense
classically you have it's a more valid
argument to say that projection care
gains are some are universal and quantum
lady it's a richer it's a richer
situation so now moving on to more
recent things so 10 recent work with
David Stern we gave a new prefer private
petition theorem for the restricted
class of projection games and this proof
is a very linear algebraic or analytical
and using this proof we obtained a
couple of new bands that were not known
before one is that if the value of the
original game is small it's not 1 minus
epsilon it's a very small wrong then
when you repeat it you expect you know
the exponential bound to have a base
that depends on this row and so this is
what we proved it you know if you repeat
the game becomes even smaller and we
also analyze the case where the number
of repetitions is very small compared to
this epsilon and this had various
motivations for the low value this
implied some new hardness results for
set cover this was a long-standing
question to settle the complexity of
approximating saccharine was relying on
work of many other people
the point is that is more interesting in
this context is that this framework of a
proving ground 0 pitch into linear
algebra extends very nicely to studying
entangled value so what I want to do in
the remainder of this talk is to
describe this say in your algebraic or
analytical proof if we hadn't sure how
it generalizes our rep sense to give
bounds on this enzyme in time so here is
the proof overview of the classical
carolyn petition in this framework so
the first step is just to kind of
explain what the analytical set up and
basically show how a projection game can
be viewed as a linear operator that act
on Bob assignments and transforms them
into Alice assignments this is very
analogously to how a graph acts on
probability distributions by taking a
step in a random second step is to I
guess describe the value of again is
some kind of by linear form and then
change it to something that we call the
collision value which is describable as
some kind of a 2 norm it is very nice to
work with the main step and the most
interesting is define a new relaxation
of the value of a game so value of a
game you can think of it as some kind of
parameter you are you you have a game
and for every game there is this number
describing the value of me so this
relaxation is another kind of parameter
of the game and it has a following two
very useful properties the first is
multiplicative et so when you take the
parallel petition of two games you know
the product of them then the this
relaxed value has this multiplicative et
property value of G times H is the value
of G times the value range and the
second is that it's a good approximation
of the game value so that
you can prove that if the value plus of
G is large then the value of the
original game is also meant it's a
relaxation so the veldt class is always
going to be at least as large as the
value but this shows that it's not a
huge relaxation okay from these
properties you immediately get the
federal petition in exponential parallel
petition valve because you follow this
chain of inequalities you want to bound
the value of the K for repeated game
first you move to this collision value
this is almost a media so one
cauchy-schwarz from here you move to the
relaxed value this is just because it's
a relaxation at number two the helpless
is equal to this collision Bay or equal
to the venue itself remember this scene
yes yeah I should put a collision value
inside yeah I mean but since the
collision value is also good
approximation of the value as long as
your informal like this then both go
through yeah okay so so so probably just
our upper bounding so we moved from the
value of G to the K to the vel class of
G to the cake and then use the
multiplicative ET to say oh this equals
the Valdez of G raised to the case this
is just a number raised to the K and
then use the approximation to say that
this number is really quite equal or
almost equal to the value of G raised to
the cane and that's how you get to know
one half oh yeah uh you know I lost a
bunch of things when I do this thank you
shouldn't be raised to the one half
right sorry but you lost them already
inequalities for one part oh did I yeah
but but it's also very doesn't matter
the end no I didn't lose then you know
the values listening the collision that
sounds like this part next yeah but the
next one okay yeah I'm sure you're right
haha okay good so this is the you know
this is the fruit overview of the
classical Tyler of petitioners we have
David and now we want to quantum eyes it
by adding this star okay so what would
you do if you were me the thing to do is
to go to two month in the top of you I
just need to your author set and this is
a very this was a great idea and then
everything else is kind of streamlined
and follows very nicely so indeed turns
out that it's say that the proof of you
doesn't change it on you just do
everything with adding stars along the
way thanks for now what I want to do is
give some more details about this proof
overview at every step kind of explained
how we do it perfectly and how we do it
for the in finding value okay so let me
start with the analytic on set
ok so now I want to say how a game or
constraint graph can do this a linear
operator the first step is to move from
a constraint back to the label extended
graph where each question V is now blown
up into a cloud of Sigma vertices one to
each answer and then every constraint in
place by you know bipartite graph
describing this constraint where you
connect the answer better with answer
alpha if this pair of answer is
satisfied with some strength this gives
you what's called the leg extended graph
so now there's no more constraints it's
just a bunch of vertices and edges and
this computer describes the game now the
strategies for Alice and Bob can be
written not as functions from Vito Sigma
but rather is functions from Vic Ross
Sigma which is this worth except you are
there going to be non-negative functions
and a function is an assignment if it's
not negative and if you know it well an
assignment the way we're used to is you
know it selects one label so it gives
one to this one and zero to the red but
you can slightly generalize it by this
giving a distribution so it will give
some number as we better to each meta
and these numbers should sign up to one
so it's like Bob is saying we'd probably
have to be better i'm going to answer
bit yes that's our definition of an
assignment now this game described
interviewed as a linear operator mapping
assignments for Bob to assignments for
Alex and the description is exactly
given by this formula you see it's some
kind of linear a gregation of the values
for both to give some value for Alice
and there is a very natural a
interpretation of this if you want to
understand what the assignment ugh the
assignment for Alex gives the point you
alpha it's the probability that a random
neighbor of you so you know Alex stands
here at some point you alpha first she
selects a random name
v of you and then the answer is the pump
gives to V since every answer to Bob
dictates one unique answer to Alice the
answers that Bob gives tells all is what
answer above expects her to give all
right so this gives a distribution of
Alice sensor and take expectation of
these decisions of our neighbors say
I've Allison this gives you GF you are
fun and point is that if the game is a
projection game and only if that is the
case strategy for Bob maps to strategy
for else when u and V so if there is a
in the constraint graph that describes a
game if there is an edge between u and v
then this edge has a constraint on it
saying you know which pairs of questions
will be accepted by the verifier and
then you connect these black edges
between pairs of labels that cause the
game of the players to win they
basically encoding the constraint
bye-bye edges so again every question
was now belong to a set of Sigma
vertices describe all the possible
answers and here it's also set up the
signal on where this is describing the
possible answer and a pair is just a
pair of answers that cause you books
okay so you know maybe this looks like a
lot of details but you can you can see
that the definition is just some kind of
natural a way to linearly map strategies
for Bob to strive these friends next we
want to describe the value of the game
as a bilinear form and this is given
here so if Bob play strategy F in a
display strategy G we can consider the
inner product between G F and G just
defined like this so it's um Sam or
expectation over all u alpha of G F at
point three or four times G point 11
it's just an inner product and this is
exactly the value of the game you can
see it this is exactly equal to the
value of the game when Bob play left
Alex psg and so if you want to maximize
over all possible strategies F&G you get
by definition the value of the mean ok
so the nice thing is that we express the
value of the game some kind of linear
hit by linear form now we finally just
to mention that the file repetition is
indeed a tensor product review this is a
new operator and another game H is
another linear operator then the tensor
product of these operators exactly
corresponds to the parallel repeated
games and you can see it in this
definition button so now moving on to
the quantum male version its own the
quantum version it's no longer true that
Bob strategy is something like this bob
is not giving for every question and
answer pair a number describing a
community instead for every question v2
bob and for every answer there is some
kind of matrix describing a measurement
right and the collection of over all
possible answers of these matrix systems
with some to the identity right so these
are a positive semi definite matrixes
coming to the identity so f vb is a
matrix now ok so this is a supposed to
do know the matrix DVD and similarly for
Alice ok for every question answer there
alison has some measurement and they
should sum to identity for every you the
sum of our answers is raining and now
just like before the game here maps so
what is a strategy really it's a vector
of matrices right for every G and B I
have a matrix ok so I have a vector of
matrix is here with some conditions of
summing to identity but that's not
important now and the upper just not
this vector to another vector of
matrixes and you can check that you know
with exactly the same formula but now
we're interpret
this not as a scalar but as a matrix so
this is again I made ok and you can
check that if this was a strategy
meaning these conditions he'll then GF
is a strategy for Alice just for the
same reasons as before and just because
the game is a projection next we had
this nice description of the value of a
game is a bilinear form we have this
here too but we need to define the
correct but in your farm and this is
what it is so now you know instead of
multiplying the value G while four times
the value AFV better we have this thing
where you take the tensor of these two
measurements and apply them to the
entangled state and this gives you you
know whenever the two values match the
players win the game so if you open this
up you get exactly the description that
is the description of when the players
win the game when they play strategies G
and F and using tangled safe side so I
didn't put it up before but this is a
description so just define this in some
kind of a bilinear form and now you can
see that if you maximize over all
possible strategies you get what is
defined to be the entangled
so you should have somebody nautically
right what's super operator listen max
matrices g mats major I guess so yeah oh
yes okay fair enough okay so we know
home besides you know about to be do
about it besides dinner so if you want I
the same method every matrix entry that
I mean she actually hasn't changed right
like when you think of a entangled value
the game is the same game so G is the
same g it's just that it's truly you
know these vectors are now even larger
dimensional in the sense that every
entry is a matrix but when you try to
understand how to combine this it's the
same Jesus that's telling you you know
it's the same formula here nothing no no
no requirement Jesus fixed thing right
it's hardly geez the same as it was
before it describes the game it's not a
generic supervisor it's a fixed thing
depends on him again
ok
okay so remembering my outline first
step was to describe the linear algebra
that describes the value of the game
next we want to relax the value get us
like that the first step was to describe
the collision value so now we're in the
classical setting again remember the
value was described by this bilinear
form F and G we're now vectors of
scalars not the matrices yet and this
was super of taking over strategies so
there were some normalization here so
moving to the collision value is it's
telling Alice look you're not allowed to
use any strategy you want you must use
the strategy gmf so basically we're
ignoring Alice's strategy Bob tells you
a strategy and Alice needs to use the
symmetric strategy ok and it turns out
that this doesn't lose much so taking
this super we're taking this super which
is symmetric it's almost the same ok and
this we call the collision value you can
see that it's a nice and symmetric and
it's like a square it's so nice to work
with and to prove this equality is very
very simple question so this is why
where it doesn't change much the
explanation is that the value is a is
large if from Alice's point of view when
you look at web strategy all of bugs
answers want Alice to answer the same
thing Bobby's not like confusing and
sometimes you want something sometimes
you want something else so when that's
the case then you know answering
according to what bob says is as good as
answering the best answer and when bob
is confused then it doesn't matter what
you do you're
a invention okay actually no it doesn't
depend on it because because it's a
projection doesn't depend let's talk
about it play smart I'm getting stressed
about the time sorry so okay okay so
actually here it's exactly the same
thing and I understand that there is a
buzzword for this called pretty good
measurement that it's supposed to say
that if instead of Alex playing her own
strategies use this GF again it's the
same and in fact it's the same car it
looks like the same kind of Cauchy
Schwarz except it's now four matrices so
all right but has been proven so I you
know in terms of writing it down on the
paper it looks exactly the same and next
is this vector relaxation this is the
main point and then really get me so let
me tell you this the way you to relax
from this collision value to Val class
is by replacing strategy that gives
forever even be a value you replace it
by a vector so it's like relaxation to a
vector-valued strategy and so you know
you replace the senior product by
something that looks similar I guess if
I should have removed the half here
because i don't have here
and there is some normalization so let
me skip skip this a really quickly and
just tell you you know the fact that we
move to vector strategies make sense
it's not stay out of the blue it's very
intrinsic to talking about parallel
repetition and the reason is that
already when you think about parallel
repetition what you're trying to do is
relate the value of G tens our age to
the value of G and the way you do it is
you start with a strategy for details
right and you're trying to extract from
it a strategy for G each other you know
the value is momentum but a strategy for
Japan's rage what is it it's indexed by
pairs of questions a question v 4g and
we fight for age so it's a vector
strategy if you view it's a strategy for
details right as a strategy for G it's
like for every question for g you have a
vector indexed by all questions for age
of things of aspirin or of measurements
depending if you are entangled the case
or not so in other words vector
strategies comes up very naturally and
the main issue is you know how to
exactly define me what what's written
here and how to define a normalization
in other words what kind of vectors are
you optimizing over ok now that's the
key issue and there's a very kind of
intuitive way of leading up to this
definition which is basically to try to
eliminate the effect of age so when
you're measuring the value of the
strategy and defense or eight you want
to eliminate the fact that age also has
a value which is causing your to
decrease your value so you want to find
how they use the normalization to
eliminate this and yeah I apologize for
a nothing as a few things better but
them but anyway if you kind of follow
the logic of how to define it it becomes
very very easy to prove this
multiplicity ok so you define it
properly and then it just follows that
the bell class of g10 so it equals the
valise of G times the purpose of age and
here when you move to the quantum a
setting the hope of a kind follows
they're very smoothly so there is
nothing special needs to be
just works the part that they requires
much more worth is the approximation so
the approximation is really the
interesting part you want to show that
this relaxation that you will define
didn't ruin the value and together we
didn't cause the value to be very large
while the game has very small value so
to prove this you need to do some kind
of random grounding algorithm you need
to show that if you have a vector
strategy that has high value then you
can derive from this vector strategy a
regular strategy that also has high
value that's a rounding algorithm so an
eight-way if you have a vector strategy
it's just you know focus on one
coordinate here you go you have now a
scalar strategy and try to prove that
these strategies group okay and
sometimes this actually works sometimes
is when the game has some kind of
uniformity if the game is expanding then
this works you can find the strata
coordinate where whatever is written in
that coordinate really gives you a
strategy so that's when the game is
expanding like if you think of a game
that has probability half a free game
probably if they have your original game
if the game is not expanding it's not
true there is something for every
coordinate it might be the only you know
some of the questions have any mass on
them and so on one coordinate what you
have is really a partial strategy and
then what we do is use correlated
sampling you basically take a partial
strategy for one coordinate and a
partial strategy for another coordinate
and combine all of them together to get
a strategy for the entire game let's say
that's how the proof works quantumly the
same division hold if if the game is
expanding then there is one coordinate
where roughly you can you can show that
what you have there is roughly the same
but what you have is now a bunch of
measurements that don't sound too
identity they sum to maybe a very small
part of something that projects to a
very small part of the space so you need
to change your integra
states to be inside that space and then
you get a strategy if instead you need
to combine if the game is not expanding
and you need to combine different
coordinates then you need to do some
quantum and a lot of correlated sampling
but yeah that's all I'll say about this
so one more min say let me just say yeah
I won't say everything I wanted to stay
here you know what let me just summarize
and then I drop the drug product part
that I wanted to talk about so the proof
/ you've you one more time we frame the
game in terms of some kind of Union
operator and then we show the relaxation
of the value by moving to a collision
valium into this vector collision value
and then we prove a multi productivity
and an approximation theorem for these
say Val class and then we get the feral
repetition by a chain of in that's the
way poop looks let me tell you when
Skippy's I'll just say that though you
know the main source of trouble in and
then Isaac file a petition is the fact
that the strategies are not take product
right you need to somehow fight the fact
that Alice and Bob can use non products
join I think it's very interesting to
study this like to understand why are
non product strategy is good how good
can they do how does this depend on the
game you just understand the structure
of the winning strategies in someone and
I think the one way to understand if and
this is the source of a lot of work in
the classical setting is you know to
find the simplest possible game in which
you can still study this question
meaningfully okay and there is such a
game it's called the confusing compare
games and it has some free questions
some consistency questions and some
confused questions and okay let's keep
this but basically prove theorems like
if the value of a given strategy in this
game
large then the structure of this
strategy is close to being direct
product okay and this is kind of
theorems that we might also be
interested in proving in the quantum
city okay so that's I think there's a
lot of work on it I don't think there's
any work on it quantum and maybe to be
interesting to do that's all right yeah
maybe until now would be a better person
to answer day but okay so remember in
this approximation stage you want to
start with a vector strategy for G and
your eyes and they have high value and
derive from it a strategy for DS and has
similarly happened is the vector
rounding a loser so what you have is the
what is a vector strategy it's like for
every question and answer for a bob
there is a vector of measurement
matrices and you what you need is just
one measurement matrix and the question
is what to do so if you restrict to one
coordinate you will get for every
question answer just one measurement
matrix and what you can prove is that
because the vector strategy has high
value you can prove that for a you
relate for you know for questions that
are paired together in question pair
these matrices are similar or something
like that or jektu similar areas so your
goal is now to you know instead of the
entangled state that you started with
you want to create a state that lives
inside this small area
if I spent correctly the your Bible is
that these projection matrices since
you're restricting to one coordinate
they don't sound so identity they're all
focused on some very small part of the
space and you want to you know somehow
collapse your state to live in that
space but it's not that you know we're
in this space you want to collapse and
it snows roughly where she wants to be
both nodes roughly where they want he
wants to be and so I both of them need
to be able to collapse their space to
their state to this area so what do they
do okay so now in if you can happen so
they use the same measurement stay right
to each one of them wants to use this
embezzlement state to they know
classically like where they want to be
and so each one of them wants to do some
kind of measurement to force the state
to be wherever they want to be however
their descriptions are a slightly
differing state so they need to do
something some kind of robust version of
this but ok I don't know where is the
money people took me out
there is as you said varies based on
this choice of aligarh and this
inspector sergeant in there so there's a
an time it states that you want to be
using to play the game but you don't
know before the game starts because the
states depends on the question that you
asked and all this Omega that you choose
which is just another coordinate and so
once is the question she knows what the
entire state should be obvious question
he also knows were there times and
because of the proof then it will go
fact that these two states are close to
each other not exactly the same with
include something and so now they have
come up with
can you say what is known about Pearl
River edition of non projective games
okay so and we'll hear more about this
in the next two talks they both of them
talk about non projective games I think
and also this a couple years ago a
couple year old result of to mind a
campaign they also proved polynomial
dacapo and projected we have some some
things known i believe that it also
should go down exponentially but we have
not known yet this yeah okay great
question right and should have mentioned
this is another question although I I
have no idea what application this might
have right just out of curiosity find
the deer randomized trial like of course
first instinct you say it's quantum TCP
store than we have seen you can be cds
from games for some reason
it just syntactically is not the same
thing God's even in them that's good
point is whether the methods of your
projection games and it is it all signal
board okay thanks so in the work with
David we had a buggy proof showing that
there's a reduction from general games
to projection games that which would
give a result for projection you now
imagine it not just to embarrass myself
but to say the proof was buggy but it's
not clear that the construction was a
wrong so you know so it still needs to
be analyzed just properly so yeah so you
know maybe maybe do you think these kind
of methods can extend to more than two
player games yeah excellent question so
I feel that the first general games then
three player games but this is you know
I think it's one of the most intriguing
open questions and you know there are
some crazy games that Harry was supposed
to tell me about where it doesn't seem
like the value goes down like you would
expect so very strange behaviour can
happen
I